police reopened the investigation into
the mysterious deaths of the South
Carolina woman and her baby
thanks to reporting by 48 hours in 2008
Katie Major and her 10 month old were
found dead near train tracks at the time
it was deemed a murder-suicide Peter Van
Zandt reports on the latest developments
in this week's 48 hours 26 year-old
Katie Major was living the dream says
her mom Vicki Hall
that's what Katie wanted to be was a
mother be a wife take care of her house
but that dream took a sudden and tragic
turn on a cold wet January morning when
Katie was found dead down by the
railroad tracks her body was right here
beside the track her 10 month old
daughter River Lynn was floating
facedown in a nearby pond is your
opinion of what happened out here that
this essentially was a murder-suicide
that's my theory
the original investigator Rick holic
believes Katie suffered a psychotic
break Katie's husband Aaron Major told
detectives that Katie terrified and
paranoid fled the house with River but
Vicki didn't buy it did you see any
event zero the case was closed and Vicki
embarked on her own investigation
determined to show her daughter did not
throw herself in front of a train
there's no way Katie would ever ever
killed River or herself Vicki and her
friend private investigator Jessica
Sanders laid out their evidence I have
no doubt in my mind that he killed his
wife and who's he Aaron
her husband Aaron major I believe he
killed Katie and the baby Aaron had told
detectives he had nothing to do with
Katie's death but by 2018 the case was
officially reopened Berkeley County
detectives lieutenant Dean Koch in de
and Daryl Lewis do you believe that
Katie Major committed suicide no no
Aaron major is he cooperating with you
guys right now he's the only one we're
looking at 48 hours would like to speak
with
Aaron major as well Aaron major hey I
doing Peter Van Sant CBS News Peter Pan
says it's with good morning Peter so
everyone wants to know did Katie's
husband air and speak with you no he
didn't answer any of my questions
including a very basic one did you
murder your family which one would think
he would be able to answer a little tune
in and find out the rest of the started
thanks so much beer thank you thank you